this happened yesterday along with
another shooting at palace station
police say the two are connected eight
news now reporter mary jane balieza
joins us in studio tonight with the
latest yeah good evening dave goodwin
says he stopped at fashion show mall to
pick up some shoes and as he was parking
that's when he heard a loud bang
police first responded to a call of a
shooting at the fashion show parking
garage at 1 30 p.m on new year's eve
appears we had a couple citizens a
husband and wife that were exiting their
vehicle when they were approached by a
suspect
argument ensued over trying to steal a
property believe a purse witness dave
goodwin was parking his car inside the
garage
big pop happened and it you know
it sounded like a tire had popped so i
didn't think anything of it and i heard
him scream at the same time during the
struggle the suspect shot the 66 year
old woman she was taken to the hospital
but died it's one of those things where
you know you have to be aware of your
surroundings i could have been driving
in and saw the people and just been
oblivious because i'm looking for a
parking spot or seeing where people are
walking
that
they could have been in plain sight the
suspect left the scene and shortly after
6 pm that's when police responded to
another robbery turned a shooting at the
palestinian garage all i have right now
is yet to be identified but as a asian
male believed to be approximately 50 50
plus years of age
that person has uh been transported to
the hospital and has been pronounced
deceased you have couple subjects
detained that we are do believe are
going to be the suspects
so we do believe right now we have this
resolved i think as you know locals i
think people are just wanting to stay
stay closer to home
now the identity of the suspects have
not yet been released and no word yet on
the identities of the victims